how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the closer that we get to the release of
the spider-man no way home trailer the
more and more we actually end up
learning about this film
now as i stated before i don't think
they're going to be showing toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man right away in the teaser
trailer however i do think there are
going to be some pretty big reveals
when we get that first teaser including
who the villains are because at this
point it's
hollywood's worst kept secret it looks
like we know pretty much all of the
villains that are going to be in
spider-man no way home and of course the
biggest secret being
the spider-verse toby maguire and andrew
garfield spider-man
showing up and at this point i don't
really have any doubt that they're going
to show up i've talked to a few people
and i've seen a thing or two nothing too
major but enough to convince me that yes
they are indeed going to be in the film
and i think they're going to reveal that
in
the main trailer right before the movie
releases but today
rumor has it that there could be a
pretty funny scene in spider-man no way
home that we'll talk about
and it looks like spidey or should i say
all three of the different spider-man
are going to be going up against the
sinister six
plus even more villains than that which
we'll talk about in this video
and just a heads up my new giveaway is
going to be starting next
week so hit that notification bell so
you don't miss out on the next giveaway
and the next spider-man video now as far
as that first
spider-man teaser is concerned i haven't
heard anything yet from my reliable
sources
they don't know yet which leads me to
believe that it's not going to be
happening in the next couple of days
however there is that amc picture going
around talking about how
the spiderman no way home teaser could
be june 10th however it's hard to
confirm if photos like this are real or
not because these photos are very easily
photoshopped
but it is worth keeping an eye on that
date and as always if i hear
anything else about the teaser trailer
coming i'll be sure to do a video and
let everybody know
so let's first start off with this funny
scene that is rumored to be coming in
spider-man no way home and i will add
that i do think it's a
necessary scene and would be a great fan
service to have this scene
in the movie and this scene is when tom
holland spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man have to
switch out their web shooters and toby
maguire spider-man is just kind of
sitting there because of course he has
organic web shooters
so you can definitely see how this could
be a pretty funny scene and the thought
alone is actually pretty funny in itself
i personally have always preferred the
organic web shooters so it'll be funny
to see
tom holland's peter parker and andrew
garfield's peter parker react to that
now the rumor of this is seemingly
backed up by the account superhero
theorist who has dropped some spider-man
no way home news before but as i
mentioned this scene is probably going
to actually be
necessary you can't have different
spider-man interacting with each other
and not
address how they're different addressing
what's different about their respective
worlds and what's different about
themselves
and that's the big one because besides
the web shooters and you know calling
your spidey sense uh
tingle that's pretty much the big
differences between them now i do know
that peter creating his own web shooters
does show his intellect so it'll kind of
be funny to see who's the bigger
nerd out of all three spider-man so
that's a scene that i'm very much
looking forward to
and i hope is more than a rumor i hope
it actually happens and then
i hope we get to see these three
spider-man go up against the sinister
six which is basically confirmed at this
point the villains pretty much are
confirmed
with the exception that marvel and sony
haven't come out and said hey these are
the villains except some of the villains
have come out and said
hey we're the villains now of course
alfred molina is returning as doc ock
and jamie foxx is returning as elektro
so i won't speak too long about them
because i think most people know by now
but if you don't know jamie foxx is
confirmed to be returning as elektro
jamie foxx did confirm this
himself by posting about it on instagram
it has since been removed but there are
a million screenshots of it it was also
announced by some major trade companies
and then alfred molina was announced by
major trade companies as well and then
he straight up came out
and said yes i am going to be in the new
spider-man film and he even said that he
asked the director
john watts how he was going to be alive
since he died in the movie that he was
in
and john watts replied with in this
universe no one really dies and he even
confirmed that it's going to pick up
right where he was about to die at the
end of spider-man 2 with him sinking
into the water so not only does that
confirm alfred molina returning as doc
ock but it also
confirms the multiverse in the movie as
well specifically
the spider-verse and that's really going
to be the main theme for
the villains they're all going to be
from different universes
and of course keep in mind in the back
of your head that doctor strange is
going to be in this film he's going to
be a pretty big character and spider-man
no way home does lead right
into doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness so the multiverse is a huge
part of this film
and this is exactly how we're going to
be getting all of these
old previous villains in our current
marvel cinematic universe so we have doc
ock and elektra who are going to be two
members of the sinister six
and it was just confirmed only a couple
of days ago that the lizard is 100
going to be in the film and this was
confirmed by daniel rbk
on his patreon now it wasn't really
confirmed if this is indeed going to be
the lizard from the amazing spider-man
universe
but considering the fact that most
villains are indeed coming from a
different universe we could probably
assume that he is indeed coming from
that universe and what's really
interesting about this
is that google all of a sudden if you
type in spider-man the lizard
shows a bunch of actors who have played
the lizard in either movies or the
animated series in the past
and an actor is listed as playing the
lizard in
spider-man no way home and that actor is
rhys vons now of course google
is not 100 trustworthy after all it did
say that hugh jackman was in avengers
end game and i think we know how that
played out
but typically people go in and kind of
edit it for like really really big names
and risa vans isn't
a huge name he is very well known but
not a very
very huge actor like hugh jackman so he
very well could be playing the role of
the lizard in spider-man no way home now
another character of the sinister six
who was pretty much confirmed to be in
the film
is the sandman again presumably taken
from
the tobey maguire sam raimi universe and
he's actually one of the characters who
didn't die in his respective universe
doc ock died electro died etc
the sandman actually didn't die in his
respective movie but then the second to
last one
and it's pretty much the only one that
isn't really 100 confirmed almost kind
of rumored at this point
is the rhino rumored to be one of the
members of the sinister six
in the way home but it's very unclear on
whether or not this is going to be paul
giamatti's rhino from the amazing
spider-man franchise
this is the only one that hasn't been
confirmed by some trade company or
insider at this point
and then of course the last one and the
leader is the green
goblin specifically willem dafoe's green
goblin from the tobey maguire sam raimi
franchise this has been confirmed by
multiple
insiders multiple times including daniel
rpk
and it seems like everybody has pretty
much doubled down that the green goblin
willem dafoe's green goblin is going to
be the main villain of spider-man no way
home
now there have been a few different plot
leaks talking about how he gets to our
universe and what he does when he's here
one has said that he was communicating
with our mcu norman osborne who is
actually a good guy but when willem
dafoe's green goblin gets here he kills
him
another one says that he gets trapped
here by doctor strange because the
multiverse is splitting open
and then he uses tony stark's arc
reactor to get back to his old universe
or at least he tries until all of the
spideys come after him but he will be
the leader of this
multiverse sinister six so that's going
to be really really
exciting to see it's also very
interesting that no word of michael
keaton's vulture has been mentioned for
spider-man no way home or
chameleon or scorpion it looks like the
villains that already exist within the
universe aren't going to be in the film
which is rather odd because we thought
that they were building the sinister six
with these characters but perhaps
they're going to be more involved in the
sp
umc since after all we did see michael
keaton's vulture in the morbius trailer
and recently the sony motion pictures
president did say that it's
all going to make sense after no way
home so a lot to look forward to
including the sinister six and of course
the big
three the three different spider-man and
hopefully we get that funny scene
in the film it would be a shame if they
didn't do it but let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below
again don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you stay up to
date on all things related to the mcu
and of course spider-man
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof